no it's okay it's okay it's good it's
okay it's good it's okay put more salt
oh my gosh
in terms of cooking i don't really have
any professional experience but i grew
up cooking a lot at home
and people seem to like it the role i'm
planning to play is just very supportive
friend i'm going to be an assistant i'm
going to be a cheerleader i'm going to
be
sabotaging the competition we don't know
exactly
what adrienne's really good at apart
from the fact that she's really good at
everything because she was the runner-up
of a top chef
and we're like the runner-ups at nothing
competing against
two people that's an extra set of hands
to get things
an extra person to run around the
kitchen while the other one is cooking
so i was a little nervous about that
we're just hoping to make something
edible tell us what's the challenge
today
[Music]
childhood favorite things are usually
easy to make but then we looked at each
other and we were like
one second what do we eat as a child yes
very very different things good luck
i look forward to competing against you
too we look forward to taking you down
five minutes to grab things starts now
i see bacon you can't see bacon and pass
it up there were a lot of options there
were a lot of things that could have
been done
for childhood favorites i always need
butter
i know when i was a kid i love cheese so
i'm gonna take some cheese
when i saw the sliced cheddar and white
american cheese i was like yeah i think
this will be fun i'm thinking
heirloom tomato salad grilled cheese
incorporated somehow
probably some kind of tomato red pepper
vinaigrette 30 minutes is
maybe not enough time to do all that but
let's give this a try
we had very different childhoods we
don't eat the same kinds of things oh
wow
so there's cream i never ate strawberry
oh really
i don't eat chocolate no
there's so much in there we can't decide
on a dish so we just started grabbing
like
just grab everything my strategy is grab
everything and then figure out what
we're gonna do later doesn't that make a
lot of sense guys
oh there's pasta macaroni and cheese is
something i love growing up too
should we just make mac and cheese we
should make mac and cheese but we gotta
spice it up though
is there wine oh it's childhood
favorites
so we're thinking something fusion mac
and cheese
and soy sauce
we're gonna wing it we're gonna wing it
you're gonna make it good
first thing i'm thinking before the
countdown begins to start cooking
arrange my prep to take advantage of the
30 minutes that we have good to go
we're good we're good you sure yeah
top chef is a reality show how good are
these chefs really
i guess we're gonna find out today huh
are you guys ready
ready to take you down oh yeah bring it
let's see about that
can you pass me the sun dried tomatoes
while you're there straight back on that
shelf
all the way back i promise i actually
needed something from the pantry and she
was right there
so i thought why not ask her maybe
she'll be nice enough to pass it to me
but
you know bam sun-dried tomatoes thanks
naina we never
helped the energy does not play well
with others we've been waiting for the
thingy to boil the water right okay you
can just stand there and look pretty
bad i can do it do you know how to grate
cheese kind of
yeah it is my first time drinking cheese
actually um and i think i'm doing a
pretty great job at it right now
i did a professional level grating
cheeser
grater i don't know so what are you guys
making we are going to make
macaroni and cheese nice yeah it's the
only one that we were like okay we both
have this as a child what about you
you're making uh
making grilled cheese and tomato soup
a version of it oh but like gourmet
nah you know just like kids eat well
ours is going to be gourmet
oh excuse me playa so right now
in this pot we're making our vinaigrette
which is going to be our version of the
tomato soup
what is a vinaigrette i don't know so in
the pot we have some red onion
tomatoes sun-dried tomatoes and oregano
which is kind of like our tomato soup
to go with our uh grilled cheese wow
this is taking forever
you have to wait for the water to boil
that's the most basic thing you need to
do before you cook pasta
have you ever made pasta
this water it's fine let's just throw
them back in there
but you need to wait for the water to
boil before you
cook pasta bring water to a rapid boil
oh a rapid boil okay all right i think
was just a regular boil right
how you doing how's it going got a
little panko i see what are you
doing are you stirring your tomato soup
i
am tomato soup has got a little red
pepper in there
gonna make that into actually a
vinaigrette so maybe i lied when i said
it won't be too gourmet
we're just waiting for a water to boil
look at she's already almost done with
the cheese sandwich that the tomato
vinaigrette is
no listen to me show this sandwich some
respect it's a grilled cheese
it's not like just a cold cheese
sandwich
jesus man can we steal some bacon cheese
yeah of course
but i think cheese sandwich i think like
cold in room temperature back
up nina back up i'ma start throwing
bacon at you
i just kind of messed with her
ingredients a little bit just kicked me
to the side you know because she thought
big ones over here then i moved over
there
with that over there it's a whole
strategy behind it she's gonna go
gourmet so we're gonna have to try to up
our games right
make it a little more made the only
thing i know that's gourmet is
basil you know i had a lot of confidence
going into this
right just because the water isn't
boiling you're losing confidence in us
i hope nina's like actually distracting
her instead of distracting me
back up back up get out of here so i
figured out how she's making the
vinaigrette she's using a blender
to make it happen yeah can we put the
macaroni in now
please
[Music]
are you done with your vinaigrette the
vinaigrette is done son
oh no don't sound scared i'm sorry
are you guys making a rue base yes okay
she knows what she's doing that's a pro
move right there
make sure you cook your roux enough
nobody likes undercooked flour
don't let me scare you
look at that butter you smell that
[Music]
if we lose we can no longer be at best
right
don't let the team fall apart now the
team is not falling apart
i will make this mac and cheese
oh my god what is she doing i'm gonna go
check it out
she's doing the thing that you uh you're
dressing up the um the plate the um
the thing yeah that's what waiting
plating already
look this looks okay it's coming to life
right does it or does it not look
like childhood
okay what does the okay mean
so you put the mozzarella cheese on oh
yeah
where's the boil function i'm just like
twisting the knobs be like
work work and that didn't work help i
had to run out and like ask a tasty
producer nearby like
please help me win you got it thank you
so much
thank you oh yeah oh perfect kid size
portion
you know you have a plated kind of chefy
version of a dish
going up against mac and cheese mac and
cheese might take it you never know
i think we did pretty great i think you
guys did really well
we're getting our judges up here to see
what they think of our dishes
great because mac and cheese isn't good
cold
oh my gosh oh it's mac and cheese oh
look at that classic little mac and
cheese
[Music]
that's some good mac and cheese a little
hot cocoa
i like the crunchiness there's a lot of
cheese in it the bread crumbs on top
that was like the distinguishing factor
of like having like box mac and cheese
when your mom was out of town and then
when your mom would come home she would
make you mac and cheese in the oven with
the breadcrumbs
i'm feeling that i see what you did
there oh my gosh look at this plating
whoa did they leave any for me
is like the fanciest grilled cheese i've
ever had in my life that grilled cheese
has like three layers of cheese inside
of it the tomatoes are really nice with
the city
and the freshness can i eat more so my
favorite between the two
has to be the mac and cheese the grilled
cheese was so good and i did have it a
lot as a kid but i feel like this was
just like more
close to home on like comfort food and
like things you grew up with
out of these two dishes my favorite has
to be
this one i think this one demonstrates
really well like you know craftsmanship
in terms of taking something as simple
as a grilled cheese and elevating it
so out of these two dishes right here
i'm feeling this grilled cheese with the
tomatoes on the side
that's it guys i think we have a winner
this amateur
versus pro chef childhood favorite food
can we say
two it was two versus one
the winner goes to
it's one thing to compete against 15
other chefs and you know their level
but amateurs you never know home cooks
are amazing
my mom is a home cook and she taught me
everything i know you guys could have
like blown me out
i'm glad you didn't vote